If you want to hear about how one dark story
point cut from the movie is hidden in the
background of this movie, then stick around
to the end of this video.
[INTRO]
Welcome back to Things You Missed.
Today I'll be covering one of my favorite
psychological horror films that kind of flew
under the radar because of the sheer volume
of great horror movies that came out in 2016.
I'm talking about The Boy.
This is one of those movies that can be fun
look back on because it is only after learning
of the twist that some of the Things You Missed
start to make sense.
So as usual with these types of movies, I'll
urge you to make sure you've seen the movie
before hearing me analyse it, so with that
in mind, let's get into the Things You Missed.
[THINGS YOU MISSED]
When Greta arrives at the house for the first
time, she is still asleep in the car, and
the driver, after bringing in her stuff, has
to wake her up.
"Apologies Miss.
I didn't know how else to wake you."
This first interaction she has is symbolic
of the time she would spend there, most of which
is her being frightened by the man on the
other side of the mirror.
She finds that the house is seemingly empty
until she meets the grocery delivery man Malcolm
and he shows her around the kitchen.
The crates he uses to deliver the food are
from Broadhurst Farm Grocers.
Broadhurst is one of the many examples of
the initials BH, which come up again and again
in this story.
The boy she is hired to look after, Brahms
Heelshire, has the initials BH; the letters
are carved into the rat traps set up around
the house; and the book that Greta later reads
out loud to Brahms has a character named Mr.
Brocklehurst, BH.
More on that later.
She meets the family and they explain the
rules, like how she is to play music at an
uncomfortably loud volume, most likely so
that the real Brahms can have some time to
move freely, possibly to exercise.
She is also to clear out the rat traps daily,
because Mrs. Heelshire is afraid of the rodents
getting into the walls where he's living.
It also gives a plausible reason as to why
she is to discard any uneaten food in the
sealed chest, it gives Brahms the opportunity
to feast on her leftovers.
"Our son is here.
He's very much with us."
Well, at least he gets points for honesty.
I also find it interesting that he tells her
this stuff while they're outside, because
the rooms inside the house seem to be all
connected by these tubes, which carry the
sound.
"And that was it.
Which I suppose is all the answer we're gonna
get."
This system is perfect for Brahms to keep
tabs on her, he can listen in on her and make
sure she’s following the rules no matter
where he is in the house, while also making
noises to try to convince her that the spirit
of Brahms is present in the house.
To cover this up, the Heelshire’s have added
a rule that she can’t have any guests over,
and only Malcolm can come in to make the deliveries,
this way she never becomes aware of the way
the sound carries because for the most part
she’s the only one making any sounds.
If you were wondering if the Heelshires are
in on it, or if they too were being fooled
by Brahms, consider this.
Before they leave, they take a moment alone,
which I’m guessing was for a final face
to face with the real Brahms.
“Could you give us a moment alone to speak
to Brahms privately?”
“Oh sure.”
I’ll crank up the volume right here, where
you can actually hear Brahms’s voice.
"Brahms".
*unintelligible*
"I think she's lovely.
"I think she should stay."
You can’t make out what he’s saying, but
you can tell that it isn’t Mr. or Mrs. Heelshire.
“He wants you, Ms. Evans.
He’s chosen you if you’ll have him.”
The backstory that we later learn tells us
that Brahms used to play with a young girl
named Emily, but one day she was found killed
in the woods.
It was most likely Brahms, who had always
had some issues, so The Heelshires started
a fire and faked their son’s death to avoid
the consequences.
They let him hide for years inside the walls,
until they can’t do it anymore, so that’s
why they pretend they are going on holiday,
where they really just end up offing themselves
out of guilt for what they allowed Brahms
to become.
They also seem nervous as they’re leaving,
probably because Brahms has become too powerful
and they don’t know if their vacation cover
story is gonna hold up.
I think Brahms grave marker is another clue,
it says ‘he shall not perish but have everlasting
life’, though I’m not sure why they would
leave a clue to a secret they’re trying
to keep.
"I'm so sorry..."
"Come along my dear.
It's time we left."
Guess they just wanted a little inside joke
between the two of them.
The penultimate rule is “Brahms is never
to leave,” because looking back on it, the
illusion that the doll is possessed would
never hold up in the outside world, it only
works because the real Brahms is able to emerge
from inside the walls while Greta isn’t
looking.
So all of these tactics are enough to plant
that subconscious seed in Greta’s mind that
Brahms could really be alive.
In her first dream scene, the shot begins
with us looking through a mirror, and it is
through the mirror where Brahms would eventually
reveal himself.
There are many shots like this that seems
to be coming from Brahm’s point of view,
whether he’s stealing her stuff while she's
in the shower, spying on her through a keyhole
or otherwise.
The dream ends with a hand reaching out through
the wall to attack her, so perhaps some subconscious
part of her suspected the truth as a possibility.
After things start to get weird around the
house, Greta gives in and starts following
the routine that the Heelshire’s had laid
out for her, which includes reading aloud
to the doll every day.
She reads a selection from Jane Eyre, a 19th
Century British novel.
There are a ton of parallels between the story
of Jane Eyre and Greta’s story in The Boy,
but the most notable part is when Jane becomes
a Governess, which is essentially the role
Greta is filling at the house, and meets a
man Rochester.
One evening Jane discovers that Rochester
has been set on fire in his sleep and it turns
out to be a madwoman in the attic who was
responsible.
Jane saves Rochester’s life, just as Greta
goes back to save Malcolm from Brahms in The
Boy.
If you’ve read Jane Eyre, I’m sure you
can find other parallels as well, but I’m
going to move on to the dark truth behind
Brahms’s intentions in the movie.
In a Q&A with the screenwriter Stacey Menear,
he reveals that Greta wasn’t brought in
to be either a girlfriend or mother figure
to Brahms, but rather a messed up in-between
of the two.
We get a pretty good idea of this when they
discover the real room, with the the makeshift
sack-doll wearing her dress on the bed, but
what you may not have noticed is the used
tissues.
I’ll let you draw your own conclusion with
that.
The doll also has a full head of hair.
It’s possible that at least some of that
is her real hair, because we see her notice
a chopped portion upon getting out of the
shower earlier in the film.
The arms are covered in what seem to be refrigerator
letter magnets, maybe the director’s clue
about the in-between status that Menear was
talking about.
That brings us to the last rule: kiss goodnight.
I can only imagine, given everything that’s
been presented that Brahms did not plan on
stopping at the kiss.
It certainly gives new meaning to this line.
“Well we’ve had a number of potential
nannies come through already.
Brahms has rejected them all.
Though they weren’t nearly as young or as
pretty as you.”
It was also hinted at that Brahms exhibited
a sort of sadistic behavior as a child, many
rumors in town seem to think he was responsible
for crushing the young girl Emily’s skull,
and that does seem possible after seeing the
superhuman strength displayed during his rampage.
He also has an array of animal traps and possible
torture devices hanging from his ceiling.
I think that means the BH carved into the
rat trap that I mentioned earlier probably
doesn’t stand for Brahms, and sadism is
one of the many psychological issues that
he has.
Where else would he have gotten the blood
used to leave the message for Greta’s ex-boyfriend
Cole?
There are plenty of secrets hidden all over
this movie, so let me know what you might
have noticed in the comments, and if you love
horror, don’t hide behind that mirror, come
out and subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors
every week, ring that deathbell for notifications
and I’ll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.